como todas las mañanas en directo
América tenemos un espacio dedicado a
las noticias de salud y para eso nos
acompaña nuestra periodista mar Romero
sala Mar buenos días Igualmente María
Clara bueno Y hoy no son tan buenos
Porque lastimosamente en temas de salud
tenemos noticias un poco desalentadoras
que tienen que ver con las nuevas cifras
de la mortalidad materna en el mundo así
es Es un estudio publicado por la OMS
con otras agencias internacionales y se
refiere básicamente a las muertes
durante el embarazo durante el parto de
las mujeres y como decías no son
especialmente alentadoras las Vamos a
repasar en 2020 se recogieron se
registraron
287.000 muertes maternas en todo el
mundo eso En qué se traduce se traduce
en una muerte cada dos minutos además
hay desigualdades regionales abrumadoras
del 70% de las muertes fue en países de
África subsahariana y especialmente
además en países que actualmente viven
en conflicto uno de los ejemplos por
ejemplo puede ser yemen donde estos dos
temas se cruzan otro dato también es que
hay 270 millones de mujeres que no
tienen acceso a métodos anticonceptivos
modernos y la Organización Mundial de la
Salud en su informe planteaba
precisamente que tener acceso a estos
métodos para poder pues planear la
maternidad es una de las cosas que
mejora luego los prospectos de vida y de
éxito de estos embarazos repasemos un
momento también las principales causas
de estas muertes no se cifran por
ejemplo la hemorragia las hemorragias de
las infecciones relacionadas con el
embarazo que son indicadores de falta
sobre todo de acceso a la salud de estas
mujeres y también de condiciones
subyacentes que se agravan con el
embarazo por ejemplo la malaria o el VIH
y por último también la bms pues cita
las complicaciones a raíz de abortos no
seguros de interrupciones del embarazo
no seguros como vemos es especialmente
frustrante porque todas estas cosas son
prevenibles sobre todo con unos buenos
accesos a la salud como usted lo dice
son prevenibles y por eso la la
mortalidad materna es uno de los
indicadores de desarrollo de un país
cuéntenos Entonces cómo está la
situación en América pues tanto en
Norteamérica como en América Latina en
el Caribe la tasa de mortalidad creció
entre 2000 y 2020 en un 17 en 15%
respectivamente y refleja una de las
conclusiones principales del informe y
es que entre 2000 y 2015 hubo grandes
avances en la mayoría de los países Pero
entre 2015 y 2020 estos avances os
estancaron o se revirtieron aquí tenemos
este mapa que muestra la variación de la
tasa de mortalidad materna entre el 2000
y el 2020 vemos Que en la mayoría de
países ha mejorado por ejemplo hablamos
de chile que es el país en el que más ha
crecido o sea en el que más ha
disminuido en este caso de hecho la
mortalidad materna entre 2000 y 2020 se
ha reducido en un 53% y también
queríamos destacar Haití que aunque
tiene una de las tasas de mortalidad
materna más altas de toda la región
logró mejorarla logró un incremento del
14,2% entonces bueno él nos parece que
también es un logro teniendo en cuenta
la situación en el país en el lado
negativo hay varios países que se han
visto empeorarla no por ejemplo Canadá
Jamaica México y particularmente
queríamos destacar también Estados
Unidos y Venezuela donde que son los dos
países donde la situación ha empeorado
más en Venezuela la situación es crítica
con una tasa de como hemos visto del
182,8% que ha empeorado la tasa de
mortalidad en 20 años todo esto sin
tener en cuenta las desigualdades que
ocurren dentro de los propios países que
muchas veces quieren difuminadas por
estas cifras nacionales ojalá se puedan
revertir entonces estas causas mar
porque el panorama global que usted nos
presenta de una materna muerta en el
mundo cada dos minutos es totalmente
desalentador Así es bueno y cambiamos
Ahora sí de tema por noticias un poco
más positivas porque hay actualidad
sobre posibles nuevos tratamientos para
los pacientes que tienen cáncer sí se
trata de la terapia de protones contra
el cáncer que hace años que se
implementa pero quienes Reino Unido
ahora ha empezado un estudio para
entender mejor qué con tiene a largo
plazo cómo funciona rápidamente esta
terapia se proyecta un haz de protones
como un rayo de protones que recordemos
es una partícula elemental que forman
los átomos se aceleran en una sincrotono
pequeño en este caso y se proyecta un
rayo que es como de 5 milímetros de
diámetro hacia el hacia el tumor eso
desordena el ADN de las células del
tumor digamos de alguna manera haciendo
que no pueda repararse o que no pueda
seguir creciendo tiene varias ventajas
por ejemplo es mucho menos dañino con el
resto del cuerpo porque es bastante más
preciso escuchemos a una de las doctoras
que lo implementa
o si quisieras tratar un cáncer cerca de
la médula espinal podríamos tratarlo y
evitar la médula
la terapia de as de protones se usa en
Reino Unido para este tipo de tumores
difíciles de tratar pero también para
niños y adultos jóvenes
son pacientes en los que debemos tratar
el pecho los nódulos Especialmente los
nódulos linfáticos debajo de los huesos
del pecho que pueden estar muy cerca del
corazón
usted ya lo mencionaba brevemente Y es
que esta terapia puede tener ventajas
para los pacientes que otros beneficios
podrían traer Pues precisamente eso es
lo que intenta determinar el estudio no
saber lo más a largo plazo ver si
realmente con los años van a tener menos
daños derivados de estas radioterapias y
por ahora también esa voluntad de
ponerlo a disposición de los pacientes
que tengan justo más riesgos de que con
los años la radioterapias o las
quimioterapias les generen más daño
precisamente eso explicaba una de las
pacientes
tenía un problema de corazón previo una
fuga en una válvula y por eso me dijeron
que la radioterapia podría traerme más
problemas por exceso de radiación en el
corazón y que podía empeorar mi
enfermedad
me siento optimista con este tratamiento
me gusta cómo avanzan las cosas sé que
todavía me queda mucho pero decidí
tomarme las cosas día a día y ver cómo
vamos
esperemos que esta terapia contra el
cáncer sea exitosa Seguiremos
Atentamente los resultados